[Music]
this episode is sponsored by fabulous
the number one self-care app that helps
you start building better habits the
first 100 people who click on the link
in the description will get 25 off a
fabulous subscription
[Music]
these dinoflagellates did not come to us
like this spread out and diffuse across
a slide when they came to us they were
living a very comfortable life tucked
away into the body of a coral
so how did they end up here
[Music]
there's a short answer and a long answer
to that question so let's start with the
short answer
james our master of microscopes recently
received a package from a coral farm in
germany we've explored some of the
microscopic creatures and bristle worms
that were living and thriving in those
packages in previous videos but today
we're here to focus on the main event
the corals
[Music]
unfortunately it turns out that imaging
corals under the microscope is a little
bit difficult they don't fit under the
lens so instead of trying to squeeze
them in james tried cutting slices out
of them that would be thin enough to fit
under the microscope
but as he cut
the corals began to bleed
dinoflagellates
so that's the short answer the long
answer would take about 240 million
years and we don't have that kind of
time so let's go with something a little
bit in between the two
at particular spots in the ocean where
the temperatures are just right you can
find coral reefs spread out like a bony
but colorful garden
the twists and turns of the corals
within these reefs create spaces for
other animals to swim in and around
forming a stunning scenery that
complements the incredible array of
oceanic life
because of the forms they take on corals
look like plants even the ones from the
coral farm look like a weird cute neon
plant you might buy from a home decor
store designed by lisa frank but corals
are not plants they are animals members
of the phylum cnidaria which means that
they are relatives of such former
journey to the microcosm stars as hydra
and the starlet cnm name and like their
cydarian relatives corals have simple
bodies through the middle of the animal
is a gastrovascular cavity that opens to
a mouth lined with a ring of tentacles
that sweep through the water in search
of food
helping them in their search for food
are special cells on their tentacles
called nidocites which are loaded with
toxins
the type of corals that we are showing
you today are different from the types
that assemble the vast majority of reefs
those corals are often called hard
corals or stony corals thanks to the
hard exteriors the corals make for
themselves out of calcium carbonate but
the corals that james looked at under
the microscope represent the softer side
of their family like this xenia with its
bluish arms moving with the water around
it
these soft corals still live in reefs
but they don't form the calcium
carbonate structures that their stony
counterparts do
many species of corals stony and soft
alike share another trait the
dinoflagellates though in this symbiotic
context they are known by another name
zooxanthellae
you can see their brown bodies inside
the soft coral xenia in some corals the
presence of these zooxanthellae might
not be immediately obvious like this
zoanthus which is under white light
those brown dots that were so
immediately obvious when we zoomed on
the xenia are not so obvious now
so where are the zuisantelli
to find them we take advantage of the
photosynthetic pigment inside of
zooxanthellae chlorophyll which glows
red when it is excited with red light
when we illuminate the coral with this
red light we see the algae then as a
bright red version of themselves tucked
into different parts of the coral
[Music]
the oldest coral fossils that have been
found are around 400 million years old
however corals haven't had algae living
inside of them the whole time now it's
hard to pin down the exact date this
relationship began because
dinoflagellate fossils are hard to come
by but in 2016 a team of scientists
studying coral fossils for the chemical
and physical evidence of zeus anthelli
came up with a rough estimate for when
the two may have found each other
210 million years ago
that would have been around the late
triassic period a time when the first
dinosaurs were emerging the waters that
the corals were living in weren't
particularly rich in nutrients and yet
corals were able to expand and diversify
in those waters and they probably have
the tiny algae living inside them to
thank for that success
the corals either inherit their algae or
attract them releasing signals and
communicating chemically until they can
essentially eat the algae except instead
of eating the corals tuck them away
housing them in special compartments
called symbiosomes within the lining of
their gastrovascular cavity and from
there the exchange is simple but
powerful
the zooxanthellae live their algae lives
within the coral absorbing light and
photosynthesizing it into nutrients but
those nutrients aren't really for them
about ninety percent of what the
zooxanthellae makes gets sent to the
coral instead that's a lot for the
zooxanthellae to give up but the corals
put that nutrition to good use
scientists studying stony corals found
that when the zooxanthellae were removed
from the corals or when it was darker
and the zooxanthellae couldn't do their
photosynthesis the corals were much
slower at making calcium carbonate and
while there are corals that don't form
symbiotic relationships with
zooxanthellae they are also slower at
making the calcium carbonate structures
compared to symbiotic corals
in exchange the zooxanthellae get the
protection of their coral hosts and they
also get the waste that the coral
produces things like ammonia that are
useless to the coral but nutrition for
the zooxanthellae this exchange benefits
far more than just the coral and the
zuisantelli it's also allowed many other
animals to thrive it's estimated that
coral reefs cover less than one percent
of the ocean floor and yet they are home
to around one third of all marine
species
also the overall effect is beautiful
with zooxanthellae providing much of the
color we associate with corals but it's
also a delicate relationship when waters
become too warm or pollutants
contaminate the water or any other
myriad things happen that become too
stressful for the corals they expel
their algae losing their brilliant color
in the process and what's known as coral
bleaching and without changing climate
these stresses are starkly rendered in
our oceans as corals turn white and face
new challenges without their
dinoflagellate inhabitants the
relationship they formed with zouzantele
may have been one of the defining
features of their past but the loss of
those relationships may be one of the
defining features
of their present
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you to fabulous for sponsoring
this episode fabulous is an app that was
created by behavioral science
researchers to gently support your
personal goals
habit changing and habit building is
hard so if you're looking for ways to
add a new thing to your routine fabulous
is the way to go their journey feature
makes it easy to set goals and track
your progress using the roadmap with
over 30 million users fabulous can help
you whether you are looking for ways to
stay focused at work need a reminder to
take a break once in a while to stretch
and drink some water or if you're
looking to develop a whole new post-work
routine
the app is 100 personalized to your
goals and with their daily coaching and
goal setting you can start building your
ideal daily routine
the first 100 people who click on the
link in the description will get 25 off
a fabulous subscription
i like to think that we have formed a
symbiotic relationship with the people
on the screen right now they give us a
little bit of support we give them and
also everyone else who has access to a
high-speed internet connection just
really
chill good videos about microorganisms
this is absolutely a mutually beneficial
relationship and if you would like to
enter into a relationship like that you
can go to patreon.com
journey2micro where you can find out
more about becoming a patron and all the
cool stuff you can get
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
you